i was breastfeeding getting out of bed
my wrist buckled i thought i have to do
something because i'm worried i'm going
to drop my baby the arthritis was back i
was itchy everywhere and i was like how
is this possible if i'd experienced
remission why isn't that diet working
anymore and i cut everything out except
for beef and two weeks after doing that
thinking i'm nuts hopefully i don't get
vitamin deficiencies the itch went away
and my joints started to feel better
four weeks after that they stopped
crying in the morning and five months
after that the anxiety lifted and i was
back in what i felt was heaven compared
to how i'd been living all beef all lamb
salt and water my mom went on the diet
and her osteoarthritis went away my dad
went on the diet and he lost 70 pounds
kid psoriasis that went away i've talked
to thousands of people with autoimmune
disorders who've done similar things and
seen similar results i've been talking
about this diet to spread awareness in
hopes that the medical community can
take something like this seriously